Let's see if we can find it
face on the surface of this box of cereal.
There are several ways to do this.
The first way is to find the face on the surface
of the countries we see, and then think about it
what is the face on the surface of the countries that we can not see,
and what can be the relationship between them, and then bring them together.
Let's do it.
The front side of the box is 20 centimeters high
and a width of 10 centimeters.
It's a rectangle, so to find her face, we can just
to multiply by 20 centimeters by 10 centimeters
and that will give us 200 centimeters.
200 centimeters, I should say 200 square centimeters.
200 square centimeters is the face of the front.
Let me also write it here, here.
Now, we also know there is another country to have
exactly the same face as the front of the box, and that's it
its back side.
So let's write another 200 square centimeters
for the back of the box.
Now let's find the face on the top of the box.
Upper side. We see that the box is three centimeters deep,
so this here is three centimeters.
It is three centimeters deep and 10 centimeters wide.
We see that the box is 10 centimeters wide.
So the top of the box will be three centimeters
10 centimeters, which is a face
of 30 square centimeters.
So this is the top side of the box, 30 square centimeters.
The bottom of the box will have the same face,
we just can not see it now, so that's it
there will be another 30.
Then we have two more countries, because this box has a total of six countries.
We have this side panel, which is 20 centimeters high,
the height of the case is 20 centimeters,
and three centimeters deep.
So it's three in 20, let me write it a little more clearly.
Three at 20,
that's 20 centimeters.
Three centimeters at 20 centimeters
will give us 60 square centimeters.
Now this is this side part, but there is one more
a side part that has exactly the same face,
she's on the other side of the box, so
60 square centimeters for this country
and another 60 for the matching country,
against it, which we can not see.
And now we can just get together.
So we get zero, it will
carry the unit or will regroup the unit,
this is 100, and then we have 500.
We get 580 square centimeters as a face on the surface
of this box.